دعونا نذكر جهود السعوديه في خدمه حجاج
بيت الله الحرام ولكن بلغه الارقام توفير
32 مليون خدمه توعيه باكثر من 40 لغه تم
تجهيز المواقيت والمساجد ومنطقه المشاعر
المقدسه باكثر من الف مسجد استضافه 1300
حاج من 90 دوله والف حاج من فلسطين ضمن
برنامج خادم الحرمين الشريفين للحج
والعمره والزياره تكليف اكثر من 7200 من
الكوادر الوطنيه لخدمه الحجاج بناء 75
مسجدا وجامعا بمكه المكرمه بتكلفه بلغت
ربع مليار ريال نصف مليون متر من السجاد
الفاخر فرشت مساجد منطقه المشاعر المقدسه
والمواقيت
1300 داعيه للعمل على مدار الساعه 200 خط
اتصال مرتبطه بمركز تحكم يربط المركز
بالدعاء توزيع الوزاره ملايين النسخ من
القران كهديه من خادم الحرمين الشريفين
لكل حاج ترجمه كلمات القران الكريم باكثر
من 76 لغه عالميه
المكتبه الالكترونيه تقدم اكثر من الف
ماده باكثر من 40 لغه عالميه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات